thank you so much for joining us for a
discussion
on the conflicts and synergies between
poverty alleviation
and climate change mitigation this is
the fourth in a series
the yale development dialogues economic
policy lessons from history
i'm catherine chaney and i'll be your
moderator today
so poverty reduction and environmental
protection are often seen as conflicting
goals
but the climate crisis is forcing many
of us to rethink economic growth
so the question we'll be asking today is
what might that look like
what are green pathways out of poverty
and how might we redefine
international development in a way that
does not present climate progress and
human
progress as incompatible joining us to
discuss this topic i'm thrilled to
welcome
sunil amrith the renu and anand dawan
professor of history at yale
and current chair of the south asian
studies council his research focuses on
histories of environment migration and
public health across
south and southeast asia julie
livingston is silver professor of social
and cultural analysis and history at new
york university
and author of self-devouring growth of
planetary parable as told from southern
africa which you'll hear more about
her work is at the intersection of
history anthropology and public health
rory stewart is a senior fellow at the
yale jackson institute for global
affairs where he focuses on contemporary
politics and cri in crisis
and on international development and
intervention in fragile and
conflict-affected states
and uh very relevant to today's
conversation stewart also
served as the uk secretary of state for
international development
where he doubled the uk's investment in
international climate and environment
and face some challenges in doing so
which i know i'm looking forward to
hearing more about
and finally rahini pandey is the henry j
heinz
the second professor of economics and
director of the economic growth center
at yale
her work focuses on testing innovative
ways to make the state more accountable
to its citizens
such as strengthening women's economic
and political opportunities ensuring
that environmental regulations reduce
harmful emissions
and providing citizens effective means
to voice their demands for state
services
so i'd love to open this conversation
with sunil
and sunil you really championed this
topic as one we should feature in the
yale development dialogue so
i wonder if you can kind of set the
scene for us
what is what does it look like and what
are some of the challenges in terms of
this perceived trade-off and can you
take us through some of the history of
environmental protection and development
being seen as a trade-off
thank you catherine and thanks everyone
for joining us um this was really
brought home to me just last month
when we had um the collapse or partial
collapse of two dams in uttar khan
in northern india um many people were
killed most of them workers on the site
and i was struck that for more than a
decade environmentalists and the courts
have been warning that that sort of
infrastructural development in such an
ecologically fragile region
is reckless that a catastrophe like this
was was almost inevitable
and yet these projects plowed on and one
of the first
responses to the disaster by the chief
minister of uttar khan
was to very quickly point out that we
shouldn't let what has happened
lead people to adopt an anti-development
narrative and that really gave me pause
because i realized in a sense how
pervasive that view is
the idea that environmental concern is
anti-development
and as a historian i'm very curious and
concerned with where
that pattern of thinking came from and
i'd like to maybe just give you
two or three examples because i think we
need to go back to the 1960s 1970s to
really understand it
um the first example is is rachel carson
and silent spring
carson is rightly celebrated i think as
a scientific hero of the 20th century we
all owe a huge amount to her courage and
her
intelligence but at the time many in the
development community felt like the rug
had been pulled from under them
and the link of course was ddt rachel
carson's silent spring
was one among a few factors that led the
u.s government
to withdraw its massive funding for the
who's malaria eradication program
and to divert a lot of that to
population control
now the whs program was already in
trouble by the early 1960s there was a
lot of evidence of insecticide
resistance
but still there was a feeling that this
transformative life-saving technology
had been taken away um i'll give you a
second example from about a decade later
early 1970s um the club of rome's report
the limits to growth
in many ways that is a forerunner of so
many of the debates we're having now
about growth and the environment
but one of the main concerns of the club
of rome's report was with population
growth in poor countries
and immediately the response from a lot
of poorer countries
was that the problem is not population
growth the problem is inequality
and over consumption and i think that
one of the most forceful statements of
that view comes from india's prime
minister indira gandhi
who's one of the few heads of state to
attend the first un conference on the
global environment in stockholm in 1972.
and her
speech there i think still has quite a
lot of moral power to it because the
first thing she did was to acknowledge
environmental crisis
but the second thing she did was to say
that it has to wait
for poverty reduction that poverty and
her famous line from that species is not
poverty the greatest
polluter and she added that the poorest
countries and perhaps the poorest people
within those countries
um suffered from problems that they were
perhaps least responsible
at foot causing finally i think through
the 80s and 90s
you see a backlash against animal
conservation projects
that tended to treat local people often
very marginalized people indigenous
people
as the enemy i think we need to
understand this history i think we need
to recognize the moral force behind some
of these arguments
um in order perhaps to move beyond them
for the simple reason that i think that
today and certainly in a medium term
um climate change and a whole range of
other environmental crises
present perhaps the most serious
obstacle of all to poverty reduction
and to large numbers of people being
able to live lives of dignity
thank you sunil and i think that's a
powerful articulation for the importance
of these conversations needing to
understand this history in order to
tackle these challenges
uh and julie i see you nodding your head
it seems like you've come across many of
these dynamics in your research
on the african continent and
specifically in botswana which i know is
a focus of your book so can you tell us
a little bit more about
um what i know you've described as the
consequences of a growth at all cost
model and and what lessons we might
learn from
botswana um absolutely
uh thank you catherine um
you know botswana uh for several decades
um after its independence from great
britain had one of the fastest growing
economies in the world
it's had a really well managed
development
trajectory the standard of living has
risen
there are important social welfare
programs a functioning public health
system
participatory democracy um and
yet climate change is uh
is helping us realize that even in a
best-case development scenario
which most places cannot realize
it's not sustainable there needs to be
a radically different um thinking about
how this is going to work
botswana is currently mining its
groundwater
aspects of climate change are
contributing to desertification uh
this is a place that had been a carbon
sink
and yet nonetheless uh is going through
a really drastic kind of um terraforming
that threatens its long-term well-being
and i think that that raises
all kinds of questions first of all we
have to
recognize that it's carbon is important
but
it's not the only um problem we have a
whole
set of interlinked problems toxicity and
pollution
the problem of waste loss of
biodiversity
topsoil erosion and they fit together
into
a web um that
is synergistic um and um
extremely threatening particularly
to people who are already living in
poverty
when you start looking at it closely
what you realize
is that you can't really separate the
problem into that of nation states in
the way that development usually
functions
botswana doesn't have the ability to
control its own climate
it's not the major producer of carbon in
the world
even though it is connected in a global
system of consumption and trade
that is ultimately reshaping
its climate really
most of the energy of this is coming
from the global north
so where as development asks us to look
at the problem of poverty by looking
closely
at southern countries i really think
as many activists in the south have long
said that the problem is in
the north this is where the majority of
consumption
and greenhouse gas emission is coming
from
we are the people who set the terms of
global trade
um you know if we were to just close the
tax havens
and relocalize wealth back to the south
where it is being generated
and extracted from already we would be
doing something
that enables poverty reduction without
it being premised
necessarily on a growth model so there
are a number of examples we could give
but
i think development unfortunately is
constitutive
of the problem it's not something that's
going to be
able to be moderated by small technical
fixes or
slight recalibration
powerful points so when we talk about
how do we redefine development
these aren't small changes this is an
entire transformation of the system
that's needed
um so i want to go to rory now and julie
will come back to you
but rory i i know some of these dynamics
came into play
when you were leading diffid um when you
tried to make the case
um for environmental conservation work
for climate change action
it was perceived as uh in conflict with
some of the development work so can you
take us through the challenges you faced
and how you ultimately
pushed through some of those um well
thank you
catherine very much i i think the
first thing is um i came in to become a
section of state to run differed at a
moment where the different budget was
big it was about
0.7 of uk gdp so
spending about 20 billion us dollars a
year and approximately half of that was
being spent
in africa and it was a time when
there was an increasing consensus that
we should try to tackle an environmental
and climate
crisis alongside poverty
so there were world bank reports and
oecd reports suggesting that if we
didn't manage to deal
with problems of climate environment we
would end up with hundreds of millions
more people in poverty
um but when i actually began to try to
shift the organization to focus more on
these issues
i discovered there was an enormous
amount of resistance
and some of that of course sunil has uh
demonstrated has a very long history so
clearly what i was encountering with
civil servants were memories of these
debates which had been going on for for
many many decades
um part of it was as sunil has pointed
to an instinctive
uh suspicion of projects to do
with uh non-humans it's a very important
thing that generally speaking when we
talk about development we're talking
about
humans and people find it uncomfortable
being made to talk about animals or even
about
plants and habitats i think that's first
thing and and
that also goes simply to the way that we
measure things all the targets in diffid
all the metrics were arranged around
100 million girls getting educational x
100 million people being taken out of
poverty
the second thing was the way
economists measured things and a very
strong sense from the development
economists in diffid
that by allocating money
to climate efficiently and this was not
the most effective way of maximizing the
number of people we were going to
take out of poverty now there are many
questions around those kinds of models
could we really take people out of
poverty in the mechanistic way that they
mentioned how did these models work
nevertheless that was the way in which
they saw the world
and those were the sort of suspicions
that people had i think the final thing
and then i'll hand back to people is
that
it's important to understand that
institutions develop programs
over 20 30 years they invest in certain
kinds of things which are very difficult
for them to get out of
so the commonwealth's development
corporation would end up
having owning a third of the electricity
generation of tanzania
and that would be carbon-based
electricity generation difficult to
extract from
we just given another four billion
dollars the commonwealth development
corporation
and it wanted to make more lending on
energy and most of the clients that it
found
were carbon-based energy producers
we were giving money through development
banks
world bank african development bank
which were funding projects
with heavy oil generation in senegal and
it was extremely if i said no we're
stopping all this
the general response from civil servants
says well could we avoid stopping
immediately could we have a glide path
could we just sign off on this
heavy oil plant and maybe in three four
years time
we can move out of this we need a
long-term strategic position
some of that was genuine some of that of
course is a hope that
the secretary of state will be
reshuffled before they have to actually
shift the way in which the the program
balance works
um i'm gonna stop on that i mean there
are many many rich themes that we can
return to here but i think it's just
it was a surprise to me to understand
that something that seemed
so straightforward and ugly was very
popular with the british public there
was no real resistance
from the british public that uh
international development money could be
used for climate environment in fact it
was one of the easiest ways of defending
the 0.7
is to say to people this is our
contribution to
the fight on global climate change um
but the resistance from within the
organization
was surprisingly strong enough for me
thank you rory and you know you're right
it's something that seems so
straightforward
um and yet actually implementing
policies that
um acknowledge the complexity we're
discussing today is
is easier said than done and and so that
brings me to rohini
rohini i'm curious whether you can help
us connect this conversation
um not only the topic but the urgency of
the topic to some of the conversations
happening right now
in development economics yeah thanks
catherine
and i'm very happy to be here
i think let me start by saying what i'm
not going to talk about
which is um you know i think a very
common response right
now to think about these issues is to
invoke the idea
of de-growth is to say that you know
we've had enough
of economic growth we need to move
towards a world where
we focus on not growing more
and i think what rory said really brings
up this idea that no matter what your
objective
is the issues do you have the policy
levers to get
there so i think just moving a
conversation from
saying you know uh growth is bad for
climb for the climate let's move to d
growth
is not going to be very helpful because
we don't actually
uh know how to do d growth uh any better
necessarily than how we know
how to do growth in the poorest parts of
the world that probably still need it
so when we come to then the issue of
thinking about how do we actually think
uh
of policies for climate change
i do think the issue that comes up a lot
of it has to do with political economy
and that both has to do with if you
think about who's affected by climate
change
but also i think the difference in doing
policies for
mitigation versus those for adaptation
so
um you know going back to what rory was
talking about
development agencies i remember having a
fast
athletic session with someone at one of
the new large investment banks a
eib in china who was describing that
they wanted to lend
for um environmental purposes they
wanted to lend
for ways of mitigation in a city
but it was very hard to get all the
stakeholders to agree
so if you wanted to change for instance
how
urban um energy system worked you had to
go
and get five different constituents so
on
what was much easier to do was after a
crisis that
happened to go and say let's build a sea
wall or to go
and say after say as soon as the crisis
happens
to go and say we need to provide those
who've been rendered
homeless new homes and i think that's
one of the one of the issues we face
is really if you want to address
climate change fully and alongside there
for effect
uh economic development we need to be
thinking a lot about
mitigation but it's hard to do
because the people who are affected the
most um
xante they are also the ones with the
least power
and so in a society with a lot of
inequality it's going to be very hard
to persuade um those who are doing well
today
to look out for not themselves but those
who are going to be possibly rendered
homeless by climate change tomorrow
so uh let me keep that as my starting
comments here
catherine thank you appreciate it and i
do want to go ahead and welcome
questions from our audience i know we
have
a very engaged audience and i'm always
excited to read your questions so
i have a few questions for the group but
if you're joining us
on zoom please go ahead and submit any
questions you have
in the q a box but i want to zoom in on
something rohini was just mentioning in
terms of inequality
and you know in line with our goals to
connect history and practice
i'd actually love to start with you
sunil and then hear from others
what does history teach us about the
unequal impacts of environmental
degradation
and how could this lens of inequality
help
inform our conversation around poverty
alleviation and climate change
mitigation and finding those synergies
i think the lens of inequality may well
be the key to sort of taking this
conversation in a different direction
because i think
we have plenty of historical evidence on
any time scale you want to think through
whether it's
several hundred years or the last 50
years suggesting that in fact
environmental
threats environmental risks fall most
heavily on the poorest and most
marginalized people
um they haven't been recognized as such
perhaps until recently and i mean i
think that's one of the
um historical trajectories that i found
interesting you know
the fact that this was not necessarily
visible in the heyday of you know state
directed development of 1960s 1970s
um and yet i think that that is a place
where we can
have a slightly different kind of
conversation not so much about whether
we are for growth or degrowth but but
how you know
addressing inequality is just a
constitutive part as julie was saying
of of of the problem writ large
including the problem of climate change
but not limited to it
um i i just also want to pick up on what
julie was saying about this is not just
about carbon
um i i think we do need to make sure
that we're having this conversation
in a way that recognizes that at
different scales in different
kinds of environmental crisis are um
supercharging
um existing patterns of inequality
and on that point that it's not just
about carbon julie i know your
background includes
um public health and uh i wonder if you
can speak a little bit to
when we talk about the unequal impacts
of climate change this is not just in
the future this is very much
now um so can can you tell us a little
bit more about
um i know sometimes you you describe
this in terms of the upstream and the
downstream and and where uh development
tends to be geared
um so so one what do you think about
inequality as
as maybe a useful lens a useful way to
reframe the conversation and two
um from your background not just your
research but also your work in public
health how do you connect that with this
conversation
sure um i think that
downstream uh there are you know
pressing
and immediate concerns like those that
uh rohini has been
gesturing toward absolutely you know
when people need to eat they need to eat
when their homes are flooded
they need remediation but upstream
if we don't turn off the tap that is
creating this problem
it inequality grows and the need for
remediation
just grows and that is becoming evident
in our day-to-day so when you think
upstream in public health you realize
that
for example in africa where i work um
what
until recently was a predominantly rural
and agricultural
continent has been urbanizing rapidly
rapidly
there are people who are getting on tiny
unseaworthy boats
in order to try to reach a place where
they will be able to feed their families
and way upstream at the back of that
are a whole complicated welter of
relationships and one of them are
changes in land use and land access
patterns and the
ongoing enclosure of the commons that is
pushing people off of their land
and also the effects of climate change
that are making it so they can no longer
make a go of it
as a fisherman or as farmers etc
if we think in terms of the pandemic we
know that
the evisceration of wildlands is hemming
in wild species
in ways that are facilitating zoanosis
we've seen that with ebola
now we see it again um with covid
so i do think uh of course that
mitigation at the coalface needs to
happen
but i am a degrowth proponent i don't
see
any other way i don't think we can keep
creating the problem and then trying to
mitigate it
there are people who fall through the
cracks continually when that happens
i i wanted to ask rory a question
because rory we heard some of the
challenges you faced within diffid
um and i wonder as julia just mentioned
public awareness of of some of the very
immediate
problems with uh the the damage humans
are doing to the planet
public awareness is growing i mean
covid19 and zoonotic disease is one
clear example of how
environmental destruction is having very
immediate human impacts
do you think it would be different if
you were leaving leading
um diffid now fcdo if you were if you
were
leading the uk's aid portfolio right now
could you make a different argument
could you build on that momentum and can
other leaders do the same at this moment
um i i think you can i but it's it's
worth bearing in mind that
um it's still unfortunately true that
most polling in most developed countries
uh puts environments surprisingly low
down on voters priorities and the amount
that they're prepared to spend on it is
still very limited
i i discovered this for example running
to be mayor of london when i was trying
to
emphasize uh even issues which you would
have thought would really matter to
people like air quality
let alone things like planting trees i
mean
it turned out consistently
that the campaign managers the polling
advisors would say rory just stopped
talking about that people want to talk
about knife crime
and and they would show dates to an
incredible amount of data to show that
people were not prepared to spend even
you know 50 pounds
a month to try to contribute towards
these issues so i think that's an
important background
um on the specific question of whether
you can shift people than development
budgets yes you can but remember that
that's partly because in the uk so long
as we had the 0.7
target the voters uh
subconsciously felt okay that money is
already going to be spent on this kind
of stuff anyway so that the question i'm
not
being asked is not would i rather that
money was spent on
health care in britain or a road in
britain or a school in britain
this money's got to be spent aboard and
therefore would i be happy
that it was spent on environmental
climate work or would i rather it was
spent on some other thing and
frame like that it was very easy to make
the argument for environment and climate
work
with the public the problem though just
to sort of
cycle back to some of the issues that
that different people have been talking
about
um i think there are there's the big
problem which julie's raised which is
that it's
almost impossible to get a political
constituency behind
questioning growth itself um
in most developed countries very very
very difficult
um even the green party in britain
struggles to actually make those kinds
of arguments
um but i think the other thing is that
there is a real problem
evaluating the quality of environmental
projects on the ground and what their
impact is likely to be
so for example if you were doing flood
management now it would be very tempting
to talk about
uh natural solutions to flood management
so planting trees for example to stop
water movement
um but explaining
uh clearly that actually our modeling on
this is extremely complicated that it
matters a lot if you're trying to block
flooding with trees what season it is
whether there are leaves on the trees
how old the trees are
that actually that type of management
works better when the trees are 20 years
old and when they
are just being planted and what all that
means for somebody downstream
who might be flooded next year and where
the choice is being made not to build a
flood wall but instead
plants and trees that are going to have
some impact in 20 years time those are
difficult
i think it's also true when we make
arguments on organic farming
again many of them are great enthusiasts
for organic farming but
when it actually comes to explaining to
a farmer
in zambia what that's really going to
mean in terms of the yield
from a hectare of crops things become
much more complicated
we don't really have good natural
capital measures in place
and the final thing i wanted to say is
that again you know this is quite
granular but
it is very striking how incredibly
expensive
a lot of current proposals on habitat
restoration
i was in i was the environment minister
in britain before i was the
international development minister
we were doing peatland restoration
projects
uh restoring peatland where we would be
spending
40 million pounds on reseeding
a couple of thousand hectares of peat
land by dropping sphagnum moss from
helicopters
right they've just announced another 400
million pound project of the sword in
britain
and you can absolutely understand i'm
now going to defend my defend economist
why they might stick their hands up and
say what really
is that the very best thing that you can
think to do with your money can you
really
demonstrate the consequence of that so i
suppose what i'm talking about is
bridging the gap between
sunil's absolutely correct point that as
a general statement
the most marginalized poorest
communities suffer most
from that needs to be linked to the very
specific question of are you prepared to
spend 400 million pounds on peatland
restoration by dropping sphagnum moss
from helicopters
or is there something else you want to
do with your money and we're
surprisingly bad at answering those
questions
i want to bring in some questions from
the audience here and um
one of them has to do with growth and i
i feel like we might have um
some differing opinions among our
panelists on the way forward here which
i think it's always interesting to
engage
in some productive debate this question
is posed to julie but i'd love to hear
rohini on this as well and anyone else
who wants to jump in
um but sanjeev kumar asks julie
what would it take to convince the
skeptics of the d growth idea to change
their minds rory just noted that that's
very hard to do
and i know you you uh believe that's the
only way forward so what does it take to
bring others on board with you um thanks
and thanks for that uh question um i
actually think that the
public is on board with a number of
degrowth strategies already like the
basic income grant
something that has turned out to be
quite popular here in the united states
of all places
which is definitely a degrowth uh
strategy and something that in the u.s
we were always told you
can't have and then after the pandemic
it turned out suddenly
for a few months there we had a basic
income grant i think the closing of tax
havens is quite popular
among the non-davos set most of us
uh are deeply offended that some people
pay
and many people really don't
particularly those with a lot of money
or corporations that have places to hide
it i think
having standards against producing goods
that are
meant to become obsolete and disposable
within a year or two
and be replaced would be quite popular
among many people so i think that there
are a number of de-growth
strategies out there that are already
popular and then you can look around the
world at different countries that are
taking on
um uh degrowth platforms as
part of their uh policymaking
whether it's the government of bolivia
and or ecuador
or whether it's new zealand which has
unhitched
its um the drivers of its policy
from a growth metric um
so i think it's you know it's a debate
and it's a debate
that many people are ready to have and
um
the more that uh we unpack it and start
talking it through and realize that
degrowth is not the same thing it's just
letting the economy
crash out that in fact it's a it's a
very
planned and step-wise move
into economic systems that are more
fair more just and that it will not lead
us off of precipice
i think people are rational in their
empirical and they will get behind it
what do you think rohini i i know you
began your conversation
um mentioning degrowth and actually that
you wouldn't be advocating for it but as
we unpack it what how would you respond
yeah so i think it's useful to
distinguish between
d growth within an economy or within a
local area
and the question of what it means in
terms of global redistribution
and i think this would go back to a lot
of the debates that we've been seeing in
the aid world and development
is that as even richards are becoming
more unequal
it's harder very often to to
have a case both of saying let's
not just have say d growth within the
u.s or
or in new zealand but let's also send
money and resources to botswana or to
other parts of the world
i think the combination of the two is
hard but if you really want to affect
climate change we have to be thinking
about the global stage
i mean i think that's one of the big
difference
within uh say kobet where people
have recognized that their health
depends on others but they still see it
as a very domestic issue
i think everything for instance we are
seeing right now and vaccine nationalism
is very much i want my neighborhood
vaccinated
but it's it doesn't really ring true for
people to think that you know
vaccination and ghana is necessary for
me to be protected
so i think similarly uh when we talk
about d growth and this is the thing
where sunil started
from you're going to get very little
constituents
in favor of d growth in say sierra leone
or in the poorest parts of india where
you still
believe there are a lot of very poor
people so if you have to take d growth
seriously
um at a level that's going to affect
climate change we have to ask how are we
going to accompany
uh single individuals or single cities
in in the rich north being happy to be
growingly recognizing the type of
redistribution that's going to be needed
and i think that requires a global
coalition and that's why i think
my push has been a lot more let's talk
about the policies we need
to you know achieve those outcomes and
maybe d growth will be part of it for
the rich economy but it's certainly not
going to be enough on its own
here's one more question related to
growth i see rory wanted to come in so
rory maybe you can
um respond to this question as well uh
jacob rink
asking about um this growth degrowth
conversation
asks when we speak about growth or
degrowth does it make sense to
differentiate between resource and
carbon intensive growth and growth in
services such as education and health
and i think um we would agree to that or
i see nadine
yeah i mean i think it makes a lot of
sense to make all these distinctions i
mean
this is a very very difficult thing to
resolve this question
of how much willingness there is behind
this
um and julie may well be vindicated i
mean it may well be that in 40 or 50
years time she'll turn out to be right
um it's very difficult to prove
generally
uh people who are campaigning for this
kind of thing
uh will tend to be on the optimistic
side and generally working politicians
like me will tend to be on the somewhat
cynical
pessimistic side about the ability to
inspire
populations to do things that hit their
pocketbooks um
and uh it's so one of the interesting
things about politics and change is that
these things are so unpredictable and we
clearly
can feel this in relation to civil
rights we can feel this in relation to
many other changes that we've seen in
the 20th century so it may be that
that this will shift um i just
i just say that it would be difficult to
find
many working politicians and major
political parties
in europe or the united states that
would really
imagine selling something as ambitious
as judy's speaking about
um that's not to say that it won't
happen um but
it it's it's going to be a hell of a
fight if we're really going to get
anywhere close to that
agreement we're talking about much much
more incremental
sorry about that rory um sunil did i see
that you wanted to jump in on this
question
no we have another question coming in
that i'd love to ask you all about so
one of the themes that came up in our
conversation is um
you know who's responsible to uh
take action right and and that um
developed countries
um it's often argued that the countries
that got us
into this climate mess um should be at
the forefront of getting us out of it
right
so when it comes to um what that looks
like
uh there's a question along the lines of
um
a recent biden uh here let me find this
question where did it go
um there's a question around the the
biden administration
setting the social cost of carbon to 51
a ton and this attendee anonymous asks
this is still significantly lower than
many other social cost of carbon values
what is the panel view panel's view of
the efficacy of social cost of carbon
and mitigating risks to the populations
being discussed and maybe i'll broaden
that question
um any panelists who want to comment on
the social cost of carbon specifically
interested to hear your views
but more broadly i will say uh we should
talk perhaps about
the us as a leader here we have a new
administration
new policies being rolled out for
climate might that be an
opportunity to harness some of the
synergies we're discussing right now
to change the conversation around
climate and development
so since this question was posed about
the biden administration would love to
hear any thoughts on that opportunity
well let me come in very quickly and
then head over to this i mean i i would
have thought
um one thing is just to remind the us
that there's an enormous amount that
they can do just to catch up
even with you know offenders like the
united kingdom
i mean the uk is hardly a paragon of
virtue it's not
new zealand right but it's managed to
significantly
reduce its electricity consumption
uh it's managed to move to a situation
where 40 percent of our generation at
the moment comes from renewables
and it's done it relatively quickly and
relatively painlessly and the u.s hasn't
even begun
to stretch its muscles to match the
standard set
by major european countries
sorry um you know the reality is
that the status quo is extremely
expensive right a year ago
like a tenth i i i'm making up this
figure
of australia was on fire every year now
a huge part of california which is a
major driver of our economy
is on fire look at what just happened
in texas you know and before that what
happened in louisiana and what will
happen later in the next place in the
next place this is just
extremely extraordinarily expensive
but that money doesn't disappear from
the economy people make bank off of this
people are making bank off of this
pandemic
and if we don't start to think about
relationships
as relationships but instead as siloed
events
i think we are misapprehending
some of the drivers um uh
of our current predicament uh including
and perhaps especially here in the
united states
thanks julie and rohini i know you
wanted to jump in as well yeah
i just wanted to um julie's comments are
a really useful way for me to jump in
which is
you know one way that economists respond
to this and perhaps the social cost of
carbon epitomizes it is to believe that
if you accept this as the cost we're
going to accept higher prices
and so for instance thinking about
carbon pricing
or you know kind of gap in trade systems
is uh very popular with economists very
often for saying you know just let the
markets enter and resolve it
and i think as julie pointed out the
texas example is actually an example
where you were trying to get the markets
to work well
and they didn't and it's good to
remember why
um kind of even if you might have a
high extra carbon you don't want to rely
just on markets
so i think a couple of reasons for this
so the first is
um pricing is sometimes for consumers
much more sensitive in some sectors than
other others so for instance uh gasoline
uh you you know politicians don't want
to raise the prices on gasoline so
having kind of carbon taxes that are
going to translate into the gasoline
sector
is going to be much harder than trying
to introduce carbon pricing
in maybe electricity or some place but
it's much more if you want hidden
and so i think pushing on just one
instrument can often defeat the purpose
because
you may just want to play off the fact
that consumers care differently
about the marginal cost of different
goods and then the second thing which i
think comes from the texas example
is i think what we saw is that yes
prices
were able to adjust quite fast but um
the invest need to make for these
one-off
possible you know frigid weather in
texas may be seen as so rare
that the person who's building the pipe
is just not going to invest in that
because it's not worth the while they're
not getting a huge return
when the energy price goes sky high
so the the energy provider gets it but
not the person who's maintaining the
pipes
and so again i think this comes to the
issue of the system that if you want to
rely
on markets and pricing we have to
realize that there are a lot of players
we have to take along
and that will often bring us to much
blunter regulation
and so i think it's good if you increase
the social cost of carbon but i think
the danger
is to then think that the markets will
take care of it i think that just
doesn't happen
so we had a question on social cost of
carbon which we addressed but
uh i'm we have so many great questions
coming in so keep them coming i want to
group together three three questions
that also relate to responses while
we're talking about responses and
responses by different actors
um so we have one question around the
role of development finance
institutions um so the question is any
thoughts on current efforts by dfis
and international organizations on
engaging with ifis
insurers and asset managers to improve
environment related controls and
policies
uh exiting coal for instance so that's
one question i'm gonna throw three out
and then we'll see what
how we can talk around these questions
as a panel
there's another question around the role
of the private sector how do you
incentivize the private sector to create
green economy jobs
that also alleviate poverty london stock
exchange has created a category called
the green economy mark to attract
issuers
for example and now we move into the
policy realm
to what extent can environment
strategies be combined into development
policies
to create new jobs that would advance
both goals at the same time so
related questions around the role of
development finance institutions
the private sector and policies um
combining environment
and development policies something rory
touched on earlier but um
all of this has to do with how we
respond and how different sectors
respond so any thoughts on any of those
questions i'll see
which of our panelists wants to jump in
rory well
let me firstly say that the
overall theory behind those questions
has to be right i mean there's this
far more money sitting around in these
great financial centers than there are
in the development agencies and if there
were some intelligent mechanisms for
working out how you unlocked the money
that was in new york or the city of
london
and directed it towards the kind of
projects we want to do
on environment climate or on poverty
alleviation that would be a very smart
thing to do
um my role seems to be in this though
then saying that in practice of course
this turns out to be unbelievably
difficult right i mean so
i spent a lot of time crashing around
the city of london trying to work with
the insurance industry trying to work
with different forms of an
investment fund trying to define green
investment funds
and the amount of money in the end that
we actually got
available to be invested was
surprisingly limited
um because this seems to be
fundamentally
a problem um generally speaking
which is that these things are not as
profitable
as we want to pretend there is a reason
why generally speaking um effectively
public grant money
is more likely to be able to go into
some of these sectors than
private capital um and it's a lesson we
learn
in a hundred different ways i mean you
know one of the most depressing things
about development in africa
is that it's very easy to make a
presentation about the extraordinary
potential of africa the incredible human
capital the incredible natural capital a
great story about how this is the future
uh and you make those presentations
again and again while being aware that
british airways is shutting all its
flights into africa the major
hedge funds are drawing out of africa
barclays bank is getting rid of all its
branches in africa
um so there is a there's
there is a problem that we keep
returning to which is the theory of this
has to be right but nobody has yet
managed to crack this at scale
thank you rory any other thoughts on
those questions otherwise we have plenty
more coming in i'm thrilled with our
engagement here i want to i want to go
to this question um
from uh again sanjeev kumar here
um and i think it's very well put and i
wonder if this is something sunil might
speak to
sanjeev asks my sense is that the
philosophical foundation
undergirding the work of researchers and
policy makers
is too narrow to empathize with the pain
the current course of development and
growth
is inflicting on people do you think
that we need a deep reevaluation of the
way
we build knowledge about the world um
that is beautifully put um and i think
in fact
sort of epitomizes some of some of the
what we're grappling with now because
um in a sense there have long been
multiple ways of knowing the world fully
capable of comprehending the pain that
some of the current
parts of development have inflicted on
people around the world
those are not the kinds of knowledge
that have tended to be valued or
influential within the development
sector um or within a lot of policy
making
um so that is a gap that i think has
widened since the 1980s
where there's a lot of work by
anthropologists like james ferguson and
others writing late 80s early 90s um he
wrote a wonderful book in 1990 called
you know the anti-politics machine about
the sort of de-politicizing
thrust of a lot of development um he's
also working in southern africa like
like julie at the time
and it doesn't seem to me that that
debate
has really sort of intersected with some
of the conversations that are being had
within the development sector about
metrics about measuring
success you know the kinds of points
that that rory was making how does david
measure success
um it may well be that you know
anthropologists
are involved with the world bank and are
being employed by some of the
international development agencies
but it's not the same as to say that
some of those forms of knowledge
um have have truly sort of started to
inform or influence the way in which we
think about development and i mean i do
like
uh very much the way sanjiv's use of of
the word
pain and i mean i think that is
important these are very
emotive topics um one only needs to look
at the
the farmer's protests going on in india
now there's sort of enormous colossal
scale to understand that
something has gone wrong you know in the
sense that you know punjab was india's
agricultural success
story since the green revolution and
clearly that
masks so much inequality um and so much
that is now
manifesting itself in really a major
political movement
and sunil you mentioned the farmer's
protest that brings me to a question
uh from camille assan who asks about
the role of labor so i think we've
talked a lot about um
you know from a policy level private
sector
more top down in some of the framing in
terms of actions to be taken
now i'd love to talk a little bit more
about um in the
grassroots advocacy bottom up if you
will not that i love that framing but
um here's the question from camille
hassan i'd like to perhaps push
on to the urgency of this question um
the way sunil began
what is the position of labor in the
contemporary moment
and and camille asks about the u.s for
example
in the midst of a struggle to raise the
minimum wage but how do we engage with
labor with regards to the conversation
on growth so
um any thoughts on that labor and then
perhaps
more broadly just advocacy and demand
from people most affected by where we go
from here
i see julie might want to jump in on
this go ahead yeah i will say that
in botswana where i do my research where
you've had
this really spectacular economic growth
high unemployment has remained
intractable
there is something happening in our
global economy
which is the evisceration and the slow
disappearance of labor in many ways
and we see that manifest in the kind of
political
reconfiguration that used to um lean on
labor
as being the political entry point
for certain sectors of society and
that's being
you know heavily heavily impinged on
um i'm glad that the uh
the person writing the question was
pointing to the u.s where we see that
around the minimum wage
and we see it around tensions over union
organizing
and essential workers right now i think
that can be generalized
globally and i do think that it is one
of the ways that the basic income grant
is just
incredibly important because many people
in this world have no
choice but to sell their labor at
a price value that is
absolutely unacceptable
um or to turn themselves essentially
into a
debt peon in order to be able to
uh transit somewhere to be able to be
employed
and that's just you know that can't be
this the solution
to poverty or the environment
i want to throw in rory did you want to
jump in on that very quickly just to
very strongly agree with julie i mean
one of the most heartbreaking
things in in many many sub-saharan
african countries in particular
is the unemployment rates i mean around
the edges of dara salaam you've got
unemployment rates amongst
young people of about 85 percent and
the population of course is growing
unbelievably quickly
so that by 2050 it's projected that one
in 10 children born in the world will be
born in nigeria
but the hope which is that you could
combine capital from the developed world
with the labor
from rapidly glowing places like africa
just hasn't
happened and indeed changes in
technology robotics
ai etc suggest it may not happen
and so it's actually very miserable i
mean
i get very sad when i go to botswana
visiting communities which
as judy says theoretically are moving
into an upper middle income status but
where everybody is
is basically has is struggling to fill
their days
well i i would say that i think
botswana's doing pretty well
for the majority of the population um
but that said
these these are economies that are based
around extraction
and that is sort of the elephant in the
room that we haven't uh
really talked about they're extractive
and that's meant to provide the
employment and then they purchase
you know in a global marketplace that
doesn't localize
production um you know i don't know i
feel like the wto
is somehow yet another elephant in this
room that
um maybe we haven't
that's a really interesting point and it
relates to one more question i want to
bring in from the audience as we start
to wrap up
because it's forward-looking um so this
is from and i hope i'm saying your name
correctly marassan blum who asks
how can the global north transform the
conversation from carbon emissions to
inequality
as well as the global north's own
history of over consumption
so i don't know how optimistic we are
that that can happen but
what would that look like and how how
might it happen any thoughts from our
panelists
so i think one i mean just to link this
back to the last question
on thinking about labor movements i mean
if we think about
us and we think about these kind of
broad discussions about the green new
deal or the linking of things like you
know the minimum wage to saying that we
want to
think about growth differently that may
be
uh one way forward my concern does
remain that these tend to be quite
domestic conversations
and so i think another place to think
about which
i feel we started watching what in the
last one but not really
is how climate change and also the lack
of
kind of good jobs in the developing
world
is uh underlying a lot of what we see on
the migration trends
so if you think a lot of what's
happening on the kind of the course of
europe
or you know from central america to uh
the u.s has its deeper roots in sort of
climate change
combined with you know people first go
to the urban centers in these countries
there aren't a lot of jobs then they
start
i think go to next i think that's
perhaps also a way that the world's
going to get interlinked and
you know maybe one at some point we'll
stop having the nasty reaction that we
can just keep people out and actually
start dealing a little bit
more with the root causes but you know i
think i think labor
is going to be critical to how we link
these conversations across rich and poor
countries
agree so we have just five minutes left
here and i want to quickly hear from
each of you if there's anything we
didn't get to in this conversation
i'll throw in one question i had that
i'd love
uh any thoughts on um but but we'll open
it up to see what you might want to add
um so i think one thing we weren't able
to get into as much as i would like is
measurement
so we talked we had a bit of a debate
around growth
degrowth rethinking growth but
that has to do with what metrics we use
and i do think there's growing consensus
that economic growth
is not the best metric to capture
poverty reduction biodiversity the
well-being of people and the planet and
how interconnected that is
so if this is a moment for a reset um
how might we change the way we measure
uh so that's a question from me but
perhaps panelists have something else
they'd like to say
with just a minute each we'll go around
i'll actually start with rohini if
that's all right
um and maybe we can end with sunil where
we began so rohini let's start with you
final thoughts and perhaps it has to do
with measurement or anything else you'd
like to note
yeah so i'll start with measurement but
actually a different measurement than
the one you talked about but one about
measuring the effects of climate policy
so i still think a case that a lot of
the discussions on how climate change
policy will happen
is is being undertaken by lawyers so a
lot of these conversations uh you know
happen
among kind of in in you know it could be
cough 26 coming up otherwise it'll be a
lot of lawyers
talking about well done or what are
responsibilities of countries
without thinking about implementation of
how you would measure it
and i think we repeatedly see a lot of
the failures of international climate
change policy
coming from not thinking about how we
measure them i think a classic example
for instance is offsets people you know
offsets have become very popular
as a way of thinking about how you would
do your little bit for climate change
but how do we know what we offsetting
would that action even have happened i
mean that goes to the heart of what i
think you know
economists measure all the time which is
what was the count of factual what was
going to happen without the offset
and i think if that room didn't just
have lawyers and people sort of thinking
about what is acceptable to the private
sector but actually thought about
measurement and impacts
maybe on those policies we would also
make a bit more progress
so that's from me thanks rahini rory
we'll go to you next
so for me on measurement i think it's
it's really important to look at
a measurement of natural capital which
is very central to the policy debate
certainly in the uk
but actually increasingly elsewhere in
terms of trying to work out how you
attach a value to carbon climate
biodiversity and people's interactions
with natural landscapes
it is unbelievably difficult to get
any sort of agreement around it because
small differences and how much value you
attribute
for example to measure and aesthetic
appreciation can completely transform
the value you ascribe to a particular
escape
it's very very difficult to explain to
the public
it's something that um is in a dangerous
situation because it's something where
we have a strong emotional and
idealistic attachment to the idea of
natural capital measurement
and are therefore suppressing some very
good empirical questions about how these
models operate and whether they're
really effective ways of allocating
resources
getting that right is going to be a very
very important part of determining
particularly how governments choose to
spend their money
how treasury success investment in these
kinds of things both domestically and
internationally
and julie thoughts from you on on how we
measure or any other closing thoughts
you have
oh you're on mute there you go you think
after a year of this i would have
learned about that
um uh i think moving away from gdp is
the measurement
is really important um as a public
health person i know for example the gdp
is underneath all kinds of health
indicators and how they're modeled
so for example when gdp goes up the
maternal mortality rate goes down
whether or not there are women dying in
labor
um so i think it's a blunt measurement
that needs to go away
and i am a huge proponent of the work of
the development
economist kate rawhirth r-a-w-o-r-t-h
and i recommend you all read her book
donut economics which puts forward a
different model of measurement
thank you julie i love when i come out
of conversations with action items so i
appreciate that
and we'll close with sunil sunil i think
this has been a fantastic conversation i
appreciate you
being the one to suggest we have it what
are your closing thoughts or any calls
to action for this group
my closing thought's not about
measurement it's that we haven't said
anything about china
and i think if we are going to think
about the future of growth and degrowth
we probably need to engage with what
those might mean in the context of the
belton road initiative in the context of
china's ambitions across eurasia and
indeed into africa
and so i would just sort of end with a
call to really take a global perspective
on this
perhaps even moving between the global
north and the global south in the
traditional terms we think about
development
thank you sunil perhaps the starting
point for a future edition of the yellow
development dialogues
well i want to make sure we end on time
thank you all so much for the great
questions and we'll make sure to get
back to those we didn't have time to
answer
uh thank you to our panelists and stay
tuned for
upcoming editions of the development
dialogues where i think as we've all
just seen
the value of here we bring historians
and practitioners
together to discuss some of these very
complicated issues in the way forward
thank you all